c'est le visage tuméfié que patrice
malavaux s'est présenté à l'audience
le garde-pêche porte encore les traces
des coups reçus jeudi dernier au
tribunal des dizaines de membres de la
fédération de pêche du doubs sont venus
le soutenir par solidarité mon mari est
garde-pêche la vallée du dessoubre et
que ben on se sent tous concernés en
tant que quart parce que sceptique on
n'est jamais à l'abri finalement de de
rencontrer des personnages qui ne savent
pas se maîtriser
on n'a jamais vu ça des altercations ça
arrive mais des pour en venir aux mains
comme ça j'emmène on n'a jamais vu ça
c'est la première fois et c'est pour ça
que tout le monde est choqué on reçoit
des messages de toute la france du monde
de la pêche c'est vrai que tout le monde
est chaud pris la semaine dernière à
charmes aux villes et un agriculteur
suspecté de s'être livré à des épandages
sauvage avait violemment agressé le
garde pêche ainsi qu'un habitant du
village
à la barre le prévenu de 31 ans
reconnaît avoir donné des coups mais
assure qu'il était en état de légitime
défense son avocate elle rappelle qu'il
est parfaitement inséré socialement et
demande un délai pour préparer sa
défense
je pense que dans le cas d'un dossier
aussi aussi tendue et
je pense que vous avez ressenti comme
moi l'ambiance dans la salle
il est inadapté de juger la personne
quand elle sort de 24 heures de garde à
vue et de la juger dans un contexte
d'urgence comme ça je pense qu'il faut
prendre le temps de préparer le dossier
le tribunal a décidé de renvoyer la
sphère au 1er mars prochain
l'agriculteur lui a été placé sous
mandat de dépôt il restera à la maison
d'arrêt de montbéliard jusqu'à la date
de son procès